bella prima di cominciare volevo dirvi
che purtroppo per il 90 per cento del
video la webcam non ci sarà perché ho
scoperto la fine della registrazione che
non me l'ha registrata ma va beh direi
anche un bel chissenefrega tanto è
natale tutto è concesso questo video è
su four nights io indosso questa maglia
da qualcosa come due settimane non è
vero che ho registrato i video tutti
insieme perché volevo che termine
vacanze di natale tranquillo però nel
frattempo vi lascio con il video di
format buon milan conosce ma andiamo
crisi greentime pietro è tutto scemo la
partenza difesa lo chiamano pietro ma in
realtà fa zavorra di colore
io passerò entrò in questa prima messa
in moto che ho trovato la cosa più bella
del gioco ma anche la più inutile pietro
a non ti avevo visto ti ho capito se li
è suggerito perché dancing cespuglio che
bello mamma mia quanti cazzato si
esclude si passò la vita essere una
lattuga oggi sono oltre ballo prima o
l'ultima volta che un insalata uscirà da
mcdonald ma questi sono scemi ma quella
non è non si gioca così a barre che mai
la porta in avanti
diciamo no scende giù maledetta fisica
forza alla sola mai portato a chiocciola
sei capace
su su su dani su no l'è presa sui noti
territorio e raggiri totti e lo siamo da
anni sempre tira subito non faccio io
faccio ma passa basta mi sono rotto le
balle
dai dai dai dai dai non ha persa
ce l'abbiamo fatta la palla è distrutta
dove si spara spara no ma dov'è perché
lo farà in alto in alto in alto al
pallone che scende prima devi rompere il
pallone bellissima ancora 32 line ho
bisogno che non lo sapevo stato dato
essi c'è chi lo do mai prendi l'hacking
sparata sparando per sé considerata la
grande america sniper america un
cespuglio esatto resti bombardare
diversi da sparo nei 20 ho preso
l'alterato 1 ace e due in un colpo io
gli ho sparato 12 volte non l'ho preso
neanche una volta la nostra volte morto
occhio occhio che sono dentro gli altri
la minaccia le bombe in campo tutte le
foto con un bilancio di è troppo sopra
valori o kay uno l'ho buttato giù e
dentro ma che non vorrei che è rimasto
da sotto questa via nel caso sparo mi
sento non ho sentito pasti diversi noi
rovato di fermi
bravo
sì tutti i due li ho fatti fuori ma
anche giocatore meno male sono rimasti
in 6 o siamo in quattro contro due
ragazzi in 4 contro occhio sa o non morì
a mazzo diciamo stavolta col potere nel
mio phone 4 potrò una saggia se perdiamo
siamo delle fibre mondiali aspetta
aspetta fammi capire dove il tizio
magari lo vedo
raga è dietro un albero per forza tipo
quad a me io sento correre qua da me va
bene quando ma i ragazzi non dove eccolo
qua e terra dai raga fatelo fuori qua
dai dai cavi ragazzi così vi voglio
giocare a calcio e con la palla poiché
ci diano abbiamo giocato a calcio per
un'ora e mezza proprio mito a partito
meritata andiamo a presente park io
seguo
segue dietro a pietro muore meno male
aiuto aiuto mi si faranno più non ha
ucciso sono vivo padroni ma poverino
cosa ti ha fatto messo fine alle sue
pene
occhio c'è un altro che spara qua
pagliaio
problema non per svelarlo ma che l'ha
ucciso grazie raga mi sa che non avevano
scarella viola era quello che stava
incorrendo dove socie morto vabbè tanto
nome moriamo intrinsecamente il pass
fatto marco fini non manco finito di
dire vado io lascia sì questi sono gli
iscritti questi solo sei in the ghetto
lo senti ghetto ma senti ghetto è
allenato ma sbatte allora fatto sei un
troglodita dentro centro gandhi
se noi stiamo ballando to valli non
uccide più belli ma lo vedi questo
movimento e bull 23 suicido ciao amici
a questa si chiama bomba sono morto
ciò vuol dire che ogni volta che morirò
in questo video vi ricorderò che il link
del gioco lo trovate in descrizione e
nel primo commento
e questa la print ashino mi dai un arma
faranno ha trovato che è perfetto
aiuto lo so ronago 90 contro nab 13
pagati per non a bolano per due sono io
mai a fare le cose
va bene ciao urbana che kakà è quel che
polito è venuto ecco le braccia
vasto mai l'hack è male l'hack è male
dani no non ci siamo
sasha di ritrovarci tu e ci provo
sparagli spalle che qua sopra
se quest'opera hi fi cha cha cha
se tutti noi sasso acceso e questi
strani troverebbero dietro albero vero
no lascia dietro tutti che nelle mani di
pietro pensate mi sono nascosto di mais
e non ci sia formale bravo pietro
corri corri senza lasciato la granata
tradizione è stato sei stato
determinante che modo l'odore di morte
su forte linking descrizione per
scaricare il gioco e anche nel primo
commento
let's go con la seconda morte allora di
sorgente vedo almeno due persone
sei tu questo aiuto ne uccidono i danni
li famo e cosa ha ucciso
sì bravo vini quali fa un e quale quando
sono io adesso io qui dentro non entra
dentro daniel vedo facce piano di sopra
se sulle scale sei ragazzi io sono
ancora vivo magari non mi trovano se mi
nascondo dietro al letto c'è un nero la
scorso dietro letto magari non lo notano
militari vorrete i corretti e veloci di
noi ci sono armi questa casa cercava il
quadro intervenire sono però ci dovete
mie quando è solo io prima che sciortino
perché l'antico arco rete come correlati
civil scemo o poi capita salvami pietro
ok che in questo supporto al piano di
sopra zona più antica fra le chi ci sa
fare
bravo vieni via sawarmi essere parma
abbiamo visto vivo visto ammazza non
perdona chi ti dà un occhio yo yo solo
una pistola comprese
no dai fan è salvato entra in bagno non
esco più ma che non ti hanno ucciso
quelli troppo preciso visto versata
aiuto ma che è perché sono azzurri
scusami aia che male fa cha cha cha cha
cha cha cha cha cha cha gli ottavi ma se
c'è gente soft soft saces 8
guardate quale il cestino il cestino qua
sotto e non l'hai visto no ma non quello
morto era vivo
era lui esattamente quello che sta
sparando pietrapaola mette la sua faccia
uno
la condizione ok non coperto tutte le
spose da iaia che male l'avvocato joe io
l'ho chiamato io ne arriva un altro ce
n'è un altro che davanti a me due
uscendo sta bruciando spalla gli spari
sono niente sono morti ecco anche a
gente che ci sarà niente
cavolo avevo fatto la giocata ottima cui
praticamente hanno visto la nuova
modalità su ford night che permette solo
di giocare su cos'è questa roba qui
aiuto babbo natale gigante volevo dire
che non è solo nella modalità che si
gioca 50 contro 50 quindi è sempre un
tutti contro tutti però è che queste due
torri hanno una forma veramente ambigua
ti piace pietro aspetta che andiamo
tunnel un giorno o una spalla palle di
neve lo re veramente me lo dai
poi si fa a usare ecco cioè fuori fuori
allora non morire la roma merita ma
questa cosa si farà male di neve e
sparando un vizio morto un altro scudo
qui un cespuglio sara doveva esatto
quello che volevo dire che se vediamo
sabato c'è perché se non è addobbato
micheli scavano subito si sono le luci
di natale i gatti cazzo ha fatto che
bello avere un gatto in casa a riise con
vuole nel caso vi steste chiedendo come
giocare con pietro bene questo è giocare
con pietro ragazzi non hanno colpito ma
non hanno ucciso tre contro lo ucciso io
ho fatto tanto
sono stato decisivo attacco a coppie
perché io devo fare la donna è pronto
loria sì c'è il pronto onore che hanno
un muro da carico
bravissimo merda danno non è il pompano
arrivato nono poi morire e si spara
spara sinistra sinistra sinistra cioè
figata tubi di un'arma e mi ha fatto
morire l ho trovata lì dentro al cesso
aia beh però la prima avevamo vinto
almeno questo cioè nel senso non
facciamo così schifo alle volte
funzioniamo linking descrizione di
ragazzi questa è una partita finale su
fortunate nel caso ve lo stesse
chiedendo la testa è sempre stata vuota
solo per fare un po di scena il freddo
che ciò addosso purtroppo è vero per
avere sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa mi piace
anche vari social come una descrizione
non sapere se non ci vediamo la prossima
da ragazzi